flying full-time goodbye chats remember
how to type I'm gonna play super
aggressively and just go straight for
the kill was very aggressive opening
some kind of what do we call this scotch
gambit h6 what's h6 play c3 h6 is like
the Mike Hummer move of stopping Knight
g5 but it's a little bit slow and so
dark in here this is a really nice seat
fast by the way it blocks out all the
light Bishop c5 so I could take on that
7 or I could play Queen d5 immediately
could take on c3 choices choices
let's take on c3 what just happened
what's going on Knight see what's going
on die do something I don't know what's
going on I want to just take on c3 but
it keeps making noises what did I do
oh the pawn stone on d4 why was I
thinking the pawn was already on c3 that
was completely my bad
oh so quickie fight wasn't possible okay
let's take on d4 this is not a great
start playing full game
yeah I thought never took because he
played h6 just some hallucination okay
I'll try not to peek anymore now I play
Knight c3 okay I like the position nice
Center farms complete Queen b3 what's
council
[Music]
you know I'm just controlling the center
trying to enjoy life I want to play like
queen sita's Queens Q oh I have Toby on
[Music]
so I can't physically move the Queen
because like the the Q key is a toggle
key for my tracker so I'm gonna try and
play this game without moving my queen
let's play your key one waits but I've
moved the Queen before also sorry for
anything the mic ce7 you have to work
okay thanks ce7 play Bishop t3
hey hey five okay I'm gonna play a
really weird move nineteen one preparing
f4 and f5 I just want a pawn storm down
on time I'm not sure there's increment
7f 4 there's a bishops on C it has not
moved yet
okay so the plan is I five and then when
I comes back to f3 d5v five
I still want to play our 598 such a
funny move
so that funds supported by my rook and
the bishop dreaming and putting a rook
on g4 and a knight on f6 that goes back
to c6 okay
let's play Bishop H for having a little
bit of trouble remembering everything
it's just such a weird position like the
Knights on h8 it's Queens on d7 Bishop
on CA 9 and C 6 my structure is also
weird my Knights felony one my queens on
d1 Bishop okay my bishops are nice d3 in
h4 probably want to bring the other rook
into play
Queen he ate Queen it
was the queen doing and yet
okay I'm gonna play play a very
strange-looking move the idea is to play
rook a to and then moves back to you
seven gotta push that Jeep on ya my idea
is rook a to to G to G files opened from
not sure if that was the sacrifice g6
let's play rook rook a one wait what
I put the rook on b1 I guess I put the
rock on b1 at some point meant to play
I meant to play rookie - so g5 attacking
my bishop can i play rock' - now okay -
takes the bishop rook G - King h7 f 596
[Music]
seems so close let's move the bishop
okay so I'm doing well on time your k-6
was worth doing on e6 there's a whole
six ring what
look b6 okay look you two I want to play
h4 o king h7 let's play ch4
now I want to play f6 with a band to
unleash the Bishop f6 you played that
six before I could play f6
let's take whoa Queens on each five I
can't take it because I can't press the
Q key let's play g6
Bishop takes f5 whoa
Bishop takes f5 I have a pawn
oh my pawns on e5 we take c5 what's
going on here
where'd the King move he moved to g7 or
GG for where'd that come from
rook f5 he takes d3
white one minute 10 seconds black 1
minute 6 second oh man
rookie 609 g4 97 King age 2 9 v g1 I
still haven't officially Nighy 3 bishop
f2 I still have bishop okay let's check
haha oh no I didn't want to pre move
that i bishop enough to play by that
fades how is a rook he has a thing
where's this pawn come from yes how did
I finish oh my gosh the eye trackers on
yes what just happened oh my gosh I
couldn't lose my Queen because of the
cute keek toggles I should probably
change this what was that game this is
my only hope to like get this mates he
promoted to queen king
ghs mate oh man let's go to analysis
port what a game what would the sent
upon loss be okay let's turn off the
speech synthesis standard oh my gosh I
mean I was losing track of everything
like when he when it played pawn d2 like
where did that pawn come from also I
really wanted to move my queen in so I
did play rook e1
I played rookie want to move okay yeah
cuz open B file
I forgot I did that so I was feeling
like really comfortable here I was
seeing his position really clearly and
then yeah I meant to play rook a to my
type here okay one so now I really
wanted to make this work rook a to work
g2 and this is so almost meats but
there's my g6
yeah I'll have to get to the chat in a
moment oh man this chat okay I'll get to
it at the moment I just want to see what
happened here Queen h5 yeah Queen h5 I
wanted to take the free queen the Q key
doesn't work though
Oh hockey yeah okay so you guys can see
the hockey q let's change this I'll
change let's make it the was it the
tilde key okay
and now BAM okay that's better yeah I
was just losing track around here I knew
the Queen was on h5 and then you had
this pawn the pawn just like going on a
rampage yeah I hung everything okay what
a game
maybe that will go on YouTube for the
YouTube people hope you enjoyed this
you